uh let me ask for your deep financial
analysis on a very important issue uh
i've just talked a couple days ago the
elon musk he wants to put a literal dose
coin on the moon
uh what are your thoughts about deutsche
coin uh and uh do you think it'll be the
official currency
maybe uh reserve currency on the moon
and on mars my reaction is that's cute i
remember elon when he first got he he
first got his money from paypal i think
he said to me uh it was um
he got 180 million dollars 90 million
dollars he decided to say why aren't we
going
to outer space and he
wanted to take a spaceship that would be
modified
using russian
technology
to put a
a plant
and a watering can on the moon
um
uh or on mars i think it was
um and and and he said first life on
mars first line
um as an inspiring
notion
and so then there's always what's behind
it i have a lot of respect for
elon's ability to do other things behind
it uh and so i would take that as um
symbolic and i'd be asking him what's
behind it what's what's next and i'm
also just on the topic of deutsche coin
and meme coin and uh there's some aspect
of humor and lightheartedness
that's that's really interesting about
the way we communicate what ideas become
viral uh how to captivate people
with ideas
there's something about taking things
too seriously that somehow slows it all
down and it's interesting you're right
that's part of human nature somehow so
like humor is part of this whole thing
you